the only thing I knew about wasps before
this video was that those flying insects
that hover around picnics and sting
people that was it I assumed naively
that wasps had no useful role in the
world's ecosystem so when someone from
the Oregon Department of Agriculture got
in touch and said that they send out
taxpayer-funded wasps uh I had some
questions like why this is Pest Control
at a ecosystem-wide level there are
hundreds of thousands of species of wasp
and only a handful of those actually
sting people
the vast vast majority of them go about
their entire life and you never see them
or notice them around the tone of the
century the brown marmorated stink bug
arrived in the United States it's
originally from East Asia but enough of
them had been carried in accidentally by
global trade that a breeding population
started and then exploded those stink
bugs are now found across most of the
continent and they consume crops like
apples pears hazelnuts and soybeans
causing millions of dollars in damage
every year they are a generalist pest
they feed on hundreds of different plant
species and they have a great range of
climatic conditions that they're
perfectly happy to live in its
populations have reproduced without
anything to check it so what you want is
the stink bugs natural enemy which is a
particular type of wasp that's being
bred inside this chamber parasoloid
wasps attack other insects and lay their
eggs inside of them to reproduce
sometimes that's an insect egg sometimes
they eat the insect alive starting at
the least vital organs first this is
where the inspiration for the chest
burster from Alien came from we breed
the stink bugs because the parastroid
Wasps need them to reproduce it as many
stink bug eggs as we have is about as
many wasps as we can produce last year
we produced around 20 000 and the year
before that we produced around seventeen
thousand and they are tiny I didn't
realize until I got here and saw them
that you could have wasps that are only
about a millimeter long they're so
delicate that the researchers can't use
tweezers to move them around they have
to gently suck them up through chiffon
fabric using the housing of a ballpoint
pen but human intervention in ecosystems
doesn't have a great history so my next
question was well how do they know what
to release and where researchers from
USDA and different universities went to
Asia to find out what attacks it in Asia
and why is it not such a big problem
there they brought tresorcasjuponicus
back over to the United States into
quarantine facilities tested it on North
American space species to see if there
were any that we didn't test in Asia
that it could also attack Decades of
work go into making sure that the wasps
that we're releasing are also safe if we
give it brown marmorated stink bug eggs
and any other stink bug it'll chewed
Brown marmorated stink bug 95 plus
percent of the time
but if you give it just another stink
bug egg Mass it will use it if there's
no other choice
so we were actually a little on the
fence about whether or not we wanted to
release it
and then it showed up anyways after
years and years of work the Wasps showed
up anyway because every year millions of
flights landed millions of shipping
containers arrive at ports and it's not
like those are sterile so now that the
fight is being set up out in the wild
anyway
why do they still breed and release
these the parasite red wasp needs some
time to catch up it's around a
millimeter and a half long it can't fly
very far we can drive it a lot further
than it can fly in a single year so we
actually get those populations started
without having to fly across the entire
state of Oregon normally The Growers
reach out to the Department of
Agriculture and we go out to a site
visit not every site is suitable for
these wasps they're actually nectar
feeders and pollinators so they actually
do need other plants present they can
provide permanent long-lasting Pest
Control
for not just Growers but the entire
ecosystem these do not sting people I
have worked with not only this wasp but
other wasps that are much larger than it
that are parasitoid wasps and I have
never been stung and I've been working
on these for over a decade